- You released a song with
Demi, Demi Lovato, this year
and it's called, "Met Him Last Night".
- Yeah.
- So I think we can all relate to that,
this is the last time
I'm doing this feeling.
I've said that so much in my
life, usually around sugar.
But it is the last one
doing this, at like what,
what was this whole song and project,
how did that come about?
- So it came about, I was
writing one night with my friend,
Tommy Brown, who produces
a lot of my music,
we write together all the time
and we were just sort of
having a session for fun.
And the minute we started
it from that night,
I was like, oh, Demi
Lovato has to sing this.
- I love that, I have rarely done that,
usually when I write it's
sort of like personal
I rarely think about another
- This one was just like, it wasn't,
it was just like a story
that we made up and
we're going with and like.
- Yeah.
- Tommy was like, "What
about, I've seen the devil?"
And I was like, oh yeah, that's fun
let's tell that story and then yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah, that seems fun.
- I love that like, Tommy was
like, what about the devil?
I was like fun, you know like, what?
No, sorry.
Oh God the conspiracies
that are gonna come
from that clip anyway.
(Kelly laughs)
- You will be
- [Arianna] I'm so happy to be here.
- You will be another
member of the Illuminati
that's my favorite thing.
- I love that thing too.
- Everyone always thinks
we're part of the Illuminati.
- They always think it.
- And somebody was like,
yeah, they're witches.
I'm like, if I'm a witch,
I have the least amount
of power in the world.
- Same
- Yeah but that is like such a thing.
Like I have like friends
whose moms are like,
- It's a thing
- Is it true? And I'm like, what?
- [Kelly] I had a family member ask me.
- [Arianna] Yeah and I'm
like actually it is, cheers.
Im so scary.
- [Kelly] So, I, it's
the weirdest thing ever.
You do incredibly well
with other vocalists songs.
Like ,one, you're an incredible singer.
You're, I know I talk
about this all the time
you're probably so annoyed but
your impressions of people too,
are just so dead on, it's so crazy.
But I've heard you
cover like Mariah Carey,
which is a hard person to cover, right?
A Vision of Love or Emotions like
I've heard you cover those, right.
- Yeah
- [Kelly] You sound beautiful.
- Thank you so much.
- [Kelly] I've heard you do Whitney.
- Thank you, Oh my God wait-
- You do the greats.
- But can I tell you
about my favorite moment,
covering a song in my life
was with you recently?
- That's, I loved that, a
whole song came out of it,
a duet came out of it.
Yes, but I love the song that you picked
because they asked me you know
- But they're gonna see it tonight.
- They are gonna see it tonight.
- When it airs.
- Well it a very soulful song.
(audience claps)
- One of my favorite moments
of the whole season so far
was the coach performance
because, like just getting
to sing with this woman and also,
Blake and John, it was just
such an incredible experience.
Like the coolest part was
the rehearsal beforehand,
where all of us were just
sitting around a piano
and just like hearing
their voices in the room
was so special because you're so familiar
with their voices because
of their huge records
and you hear them all the time but.
- No, it was fun, it was my favorite part.
- [Arianna] It was so
special what a cool memory.
- Yeah
- I was like, I gotta sing
now that's not fair but
- Shut up, Oh my God, no,
wait, I have this question
because Meghan Trainor
said, she told us that
she likes to play rough
tracks for Uber drivers,
which is the most random thing.
She's like, I just want to
see what they think, you know.
Have you ever played like
songs before they come out
for anybody just to get
like a taste test of what
- Yes Of course, yeah, you
mean like before the label
- [Kelly] Like friends or like yeah,
before the label before anyone.
- Oh everybody before the label.
- Yes
- As many as I can find
- I need an army behind
me saying it's good.
- Sorry my friends I'm sorry, thank you,
I'm just kidding, for
everything. I love you guys.
- But have you ever done that?
Just played it for randos.
- Of course, I, I have like a
couple of very close friends
that I met through the internet,
through being fans of mine,
like four or five years ago
we became very close
and like with Sweetener,
and Thank You Next and Positions like
they heard all of it and
more that didn't make it
beforehand and helped me put together.
And I trust them with everything because
they are the people that I, I care about
touching with this music the most.
- [Kelly] Yeah
- So I do, I have so much respect
for what the label has to say,
I appreciate it and like my, you know,
the team and those people,
but at the same time,
I really value what
- [Kelly] The people who
are following you say.
- My fans have to say
- Yeah. I think that's way
more important. I think.
- Here's a thing though have you ever
had this moment happen where
I'm like listening to mixes,
like the mixing and mastering
actually you've come
to all the songs and everybody's,
and you're making sure the records okay,
And I have been like in my car,
like after dropping a kid off somewhere
or whatever, and like jamming to it,
just, you know, really wanting to hear it.
And then someone next to you
is like, is that your new song?
(Audience laughs)
And I'm like and you feel like such a tool
cause you're jamming to yourself.
- [Arianna] That's incredible,
did you, did you say, yeah.
Do you like it?
- I literally was like, oh my God.
I was like, I was like, no
no no I defended myself.
I was like, no, no, no, no, no,
I'm mixed. I'm listening to the mix.
I have to approve the mix,
I just don't jam to myself at red lights.
- You like no, I have
some notes on the high-end
and I'm telling them to fix it I swear.
- Yeah, these girls are
just hanging out the side
and I was like, oh God,
I feel like such a tool.
- I would have died, its so fun.
- Yeah. And then I was like, yes, it is
and so I flap my window
and I let them hear it, so.
- Have you ever drive past those
Hollywood tour truck things
- And wave.
- Oh no sometimes they're like looking,
they're like taking pictures
of someone over there
and I'm like wrong way and
I pull off and just be off.
- Wrong way! That happens on this lot.
Every time I drive from
this set to the Voice,
the bus to the Universal
like tour comes through
and I'm always like waving
and we're always laughing,
cause they're like, well, I tried to wave
they're all looking at the posters.
Yeah,like the poster is cool,
but the real thing might be better.
I don't know.